if you want to know what the key to
happiness is it's struggle this is the
thing that I'm not sure about hey
friends and welcome back to Deep dive
the weekly podcast where it's my immense
pleasure to sit down with authors
entrepreneurs creators academics and
other inspiring people and we find out
how they got to where they are and what
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help build a life that we love
what you're about to hear is an
interview between me and the wonderful
Cody Sanchez now Cody has an incredibly
inspiring story she started her career
as a journalist covering human
trafficking and she was confronted with
extreme violence and the worst of
Humanity on a daily basis and then after
a few years of that she made a hot pivot
into the world of Finance I saw things
that that I don't think most people in
the UK or the the us see I wanted to
understand money I didn't come from it
but I thought maybe if I understand
money then I could understand this thing
called power and I could help more
people have it but I could also protect
myself too and since entering the world
of Finance she's become a partner at a
private Equity Firm and she's the
founder of contrarian thinking and
unconventional Acquisitions I buy bar in
businesses and what I mean by that is
that I buy mom and pop businesses all
around the US and then I talk about it
on the internet in the conversation we
talk about how most of us including Cody
don't really have linear career paths
and actually trying different things
early on and skill stacking will get you
into the best position to be successful
however you define that further on in
life we talk a lot about hustle culture
and this idea between sort of working
hard and working smart and Cody shares
her advice for women in the workplace as
well I've found it to be a huge benefit
that I'm a woman in the workplace one of
my mentors told me something that I
thought was kind of true he's like the
men that work with you typically either
want to bother you friend you or they
want to [__] you
Cody welcome to the show thank you how
would you describe what you do to people
who might not know you I buy boring
businesses is usually what I say unless
I'm sitting next to somebody on an
airplane then I just tell them I'm like
a salesperson so that they you know
nobody wants to talk on airplanes right
yeah so so that's that would be my go-to
there but otherwise I say I buy bar in
businesses and um and what I mean by
that is that I buy mom and pop
businesses all around the US and then I
talk about it on the internet and
apparently people find that interesting
these days it's nice yeah how how did
you how did you get here how did how did
you end up winding from starting out as
a journalist it's my understanding to
ending up buying boring businesses I
don't believe that humans have linear
paths ever anyone who has had an
interesting career in my opinion has had
a complete Divergent set of experiences
like I was sitting next to yesterday so
recency biased this guy Jeffrey Kent who
started Abercrombie in Kent and he was
telling me about you know his first
business he ran a safari and then he
sold shoes and he did all of these
unique things that end up skill stacking
you to some position where nobody else
can be better at it than you and so
thankfully that was mine I started off
as a journalist human trafficking
coverage along the U.S Mexico border so
the cool part about that is it really
teaches you context you know I saw
things that that I don't think most
people in the UK or the the us see right
like real death and despair and horror
and struggle and I did that for a year
when I was still in college and and that
taught me one that I didn't want to live
in that world that I have a lot of
empathy for journalists now because when
you are confronted with extreme violence
and the worst of humanity what do you
end up doing often believe that humans
can do the worst and so I wanted a
little bit more of a light instead of to
live in the darkness and
um and so I moved as one naturally went
to finance but really that came because
I was going to go into law and politics
similar to you you were going to do the
doctor thing immigrant of course my
family is immigrants as well so a lawyer
could be reputable but I realized very
quickly that I didn't want to fight for
a living either and so I was starting to
think what are the second and third
order effects of choosing a job and I
had an incredible Professor
International torts and we sat down one
night and he said you know why do you
think that these people you're covering
along the U.S border live such a
different life than you and the
immediate reaction is well I'm American
and they're Mexican he's like well let's
stress test that he's like do you know
Mexicans who live incredible and better
lives than you of course yeah sure I do
so what's the difference your last name
is Sanchez their last name is Sanchez
you have brown hair they do too and what
we came to is that the difference
between humans who have a lot of power
and have incredible lives and those who
don't is really one thing it's green and
it's money and so I wanted to understand
money I didn't come from it I didn't
have a lot of it I didn't know anything
about it but I thought maybe if I
understand money then I could understand
this thing called power and I could help
more people have it but I could also
protect myself too so that's when I
started climbing up the rings of Finance
but I think without journalism to ask a
lot of questions without the difficulty
of seeing real struggle I wouldn't have
wanted to work you know 70 hour weeks at
Goldman and so without all of those
things I couldn't have gotten here
was there one specific moment that made
you realize that the journalism thing
wasn't for you yeah
um there's this woman uh her name was
Carmelita she since passed but um I
covered her in a project called um Los
abandonados the abandoned and
um she was elderly and was left behind
on the border which is a very normal
happening in the U.S because they cross
his families they get separated the
coyotes separate them and so she had
been by herself for like 10 years and
Ali if you could imagine like the most
derelict you know multi-story flat in
London just awful location
um old neglected sort of like frumpy
beds that she was laying in bed sores
and it's full with like hundreds of
these elderly people and so I wrote the
story on Carmelita and she was so cute
she had like three teeth she always wore
this little pink beanie she had a bear I
can't remember what the bear's name was
now a little teddy bear that she kept
with her that was from her grandson and
um we covered her story and she got all
this press we won the Howard F Buffett
award for print journalism I got a bunch
of job offers and I went back to go give
her we won some prize money so I gave
the prize money to the clinic she wasn't
really in her right mind enough to take
the money direct and uh and I showed her
the prizes and she was like Carino which
means like deer like now that America
knows this is amazing like you're going
to connect us with our families you're
going to fix it and I was like oh [__]
no like America doesn't care you know
like Kim Kardashian did something
Britney Spears shaved her head and
you're forgotten and so that's when I
realized oh man I don't want to just
tell people stories uh I want to try to
help people write different ones and I
don't think journalism is always the
best way to do that
so then the switch to finance how did
that how did that go well that really
came from a late night conversation with
my professor where you know I realized
that I wanted to have some impact it was
like my little quarter life crisis you
know at 21 and feeling high and mighty
like one person could change the world
and uh and I'm sitting down to speak
with him uh after we had taken one of
our tests and he was one of those rare
teachers you know that actually sit down
with their students really want to know
you I went to Arizona State University
huge school you know my classes were 300
500 people but this one was small it was
in the Honors College and
um and I told him well I think I should
go into politics because politics will
change things and he was like who do you
think uh pays the politicians you know
who do you think if you can go down to
the basis level who is the string puller
and and his belief and I think mine was
too over you know many of these
conversations is that the people with
money rule the world and you can see it
I mean even if you want to get crazy
conspiracy theorists on either side of
the the aisle you can see that the big
backers are the ones that put candidates
in office and so I thought maybe we just
need to get as much money as possible
and help other people get money as
possible because then if you have money
you're a lot harder to kill you're a lot
harder to do things too you're a lot
harder to push around because you have
options uh and so that's what brought me
to finance and I thought well first I
just have to go understand it hmm
so what was the finance journey and how
did that culminate in I guess leaving
Finance to be a entrepreneur slash
investor yeah well I knew nothing about
Finance so getting into Finance was kind
of hard
um but I have a theory called get in the
game and basically I think if you want
to go play a game you need to to go
where it's played like it's not that
confusing or difficult most people say
they want to make a career change and
then they send out their resume to a
bunch of different sites and they hope
that they get a job and the best way to
do it in my opinion is go where people
who are experts in the field are playing
so uh what I did is I ended up going to
a bunch of events and conferences I went
to every finance and money and wealth
and investing conference and event I
could find and as a student there are a
bunch that are free right so I don't
know I must have gone to 30 of them 40
of them and most of them nothing really
happened but I learned a few things I
got the right words right because every
industry has the vernacular you know
that medicine and
um and then one day I went to an event
that I really didn't want to go to it
was like I had a long day of classes and
I was late and then I I ended up going
no matter what
um my mom has a saying which is always
show up and then look for the exit so
you can go
note the exit at any time you can leave
but just step your foot in the door
because that's when magic happens kind
of like that line in Tolkien right you
know it's a it's an amazing thing what
happens or it's a dangerous thing what
happens when you step one foot outside
your door that was from The Hobbit for
you nerds like me who like that Ollie
and I were talking Harry Potter so I was
gonna see if I could be cool like him
um so so I went and I listened to this
event and I didn't know anything about
anything but I was curious as a
journalist so I asked a lot of questions
and the woman who sat next to me ended
up being a recruiter for a company
called Vanguard which is one of the
largest investors investment firms in
the world and so she because of all my
pestering her I guess thought that was
unique everybody loves to hear their own
voice and and so asked me to interview
for their rotational development program
and if you're young these days everybody
tells you to go be an entrepreneur I
actually think you should do the
opposite I think you should go learn on
somebody else's dime because Vanguard
puts in it on average a hundred thousand
dollars worth of training into every
renew hire I would never stay at
Vanguard I didn't like the place but I
loved starting there because they train
you I got licensed and I got to learn on
somebody else's dime when you come out
of college typically and especially if
you don't go to college I feel like you
have a lot of rough edges you know you
make faux pas constantly in business you
don't know the language or the context
and going to a corporation I think
actually teaches you a ton so I'm a big
advocate for starting and then go do
your own thing but these days I feel
like everybody wants to be a YouTube
Star right away and you've met a lot of
Young YouTube Stars too half the time
I'm like you guys couldn't [__] exist
out in the real world for four seconds
because
um you don't have a lot of contacts for
for what else Works in this world of
ours on that note so the whole um what
to do with your career when you're when
you're young
um one view is
if you want to be an entrepreneur just
go straight into it yeah well another
viewers if you want to be an
entrepreneur you can learn on someone
else's time
um I was interviewing someone else on
the Pod Dan Priestley and his view was
if you want to be an entrepreneur uh
learn on someone else's dime but try and
get a job when a company that has fewer
than 10 people because if you work for a
big corporate the uh you just learn a
lot less about the whole business than
you would if you're working in like a
eight-man whatever
team where you actually have visibility
over revenues profits all that kind of
stuff what's your what's your take on
that I I think I'm of two minds one I
don't think there's only one right path
do either I think the smart thing though
is if you can learn on other people's
time that's really helpful because
you'll never bankrupt yourself while
working a salary right and so
um that is a really big Safeguard
because what I like to to make sure
people don't do is there's a lot of like
um hustle porn out there right like
sleep on your couch for 47 years and you
know only eat ramen noodles and that's
okay but I'm not sure it's necessary and
I also think it's a dangerous road to
think that way because you know in
America for instance people on average
have less than two weeks of cash on hand
so if we're out there telling people all
the time to go risk it all not everybody
makes it so let's give them like a
little buffer you know and it's okay to
have a little buffer don't let anybody
tell you that you have to hustle and
focus on the one thing and Gary your V
garyvee your way to success I don't
think you have to even though I like the
guy um um
so I think you can do either the one
thing I liked about the corporate
structure
is they they spend they have so much
extra Capital that they can spend a lot
on you you know and startups me too I
have like three dimes to rub together
you know like I don't training or like
when somebody asks me do I get training
if I come on board I'm like
next company there's no training here
um we're too young we're too small we
don't have time it's like get in do
whatever you can do the other thing
about startups that's dangerous is they
grow so fast if you're at a good one
that if you are not a self-grower you
will be quickly outgrown in a startup
and so I'm sure you've experienced it
too in most of my startups we've you
know 3xed every year and so if somebody
cannot 3x themselves in a year they
can't stay in the startup because we're
moving too fast and so you have to be
careful I think if you go to a startup
and you think I'm just going to like
learn a little bit as I go uh-uh this is
like death by firehouse and so yes you
can do the eight to ten company but if
you're the type of person where you need
a little bit more time and you want to
want to give yourself a bigger barrier
between
um you know your ability to have to
level up immediately in a startup then I
like the corporate route and I'm not
saying it's fun it's awful I hated
working in corporations it's not fun but
just because it's not fun doesn't mean
it's not good
what were some of the lessons that you
took away from those early days at
Vanguard
well Vanguard
I hope I mean here goes any chance they
ever sponsor us to say anything but
Vanguard was the worst I hated that
place but the reason why is it just
wasn't a good culture fit for me
um I like meritocracies I want to be
somewhere aware
um the cream Rises to the Top If I am
working harder than everybody I can make
more money I can progress and vanguard's
a little bit like the military it's like
every three years you can move you can
be an individual contributor or you can
be a leader there's not a lot of
cross-pollination they're super rigid
and so for some people that's amazing it
was awful for me but the lesson I
learned there is there is this one time
uh I was brand new to the job so I was
like a year in and I was right out of
college
and I was killing myself for this job
because I didn't know anything about
finance and so every day I went in there
thinking they're gonna find out that I
don't know what I'm doing and then
they're gonna kick me out of this place
and everybody else it was part of the
program had these fancy degrees I went
to a party school basically
and so um I had this idea Ollie I I
really believe in whatever you're
bringing you know you talked about the
fact that you're Pakistani and a doctor
and now you do this stuff online as well
you have this unique
amalgamation of skills right that not
very many other people have and so I had
that at the time in a different way I
was in finance and I also spoke Spanish
and and was Latino and they were trying
to break into Latin America and I had
this idea for them on how to do that and
so I went and pitched it to my boss
because at the end of our rotational
program
um you got put in different spots so I
was trying to come up with my own job
basically which is a great way to make
more money and do what you like to do is
make your boss's job easy come up with a
solution that you can solve and uh and I
came up with this idea and he was like
this is actually pretty good Let Me
Pitch it up the ladder so we did they
were like great we're gonna do it would
you be able to move to do this job yes
I'm in I'm breaking my lease I'm telling
my parents I'm doing all this stuff
three hours later he calls me back to
his office and he sits me down kind of
like this in a little room and a little
one little glass rooms and he's like
um I'm all excited I think I'm [__]
moving to Latin America this is gonna be
amazing and he's like uh what do you
think your peers think about you and I
was like uh no idea I thought we were
talking I don't know what do you mean
and he's like uh well you know your
peers think you would leave dead bodies
behind you to get ahead I was like and
I'm you know 21. so I'm like trying not
to cry you know I'm I don't even know
what emotions are going through me and
I'm like you're gonna I I need to
explain a little bit more Ron I don't
understand what you're saying and he's
like you know we went to run you up the
ladder and this is the feedback you know
from your peers
and so I just kind of I was like can you
explain to me why like do they mean
physically I'm kind of little like I
don't think I could be murdering anybody
anytime soon but okay and he's like well
for instance you know when you're at
work you don't plan any of the lunch
parties or the outings like some of the
other people do when they come to your
desk you're very focused you're not
talkative like you don't help them solve
their problems and basically you know
that duck how they show the duck like
gliding but underneath these like this
you know that was me and so I was just
trying to keep up but what they saw was
closed selfish self-interested focused
when what it really was is I was just I
was barely treading water and that
taught me that I never want to be at a
place again
where somebody else's perception of me
could be the thing that holds me back it
had to be my performance
um and and he said that line to me which
is what is that line everybody always
says it's like perception is reality
and I remember he looked at me and said
that and I said that's so ridiculous
it's absolutely not reality and uh but
that is true and so if you're in a big
Corporation perception is reality it is
politics gamified and so you have to
play the game which is something I
always was bad at doing um
so what happened next
so then uh he gave the job actually to
somebody so he took my idea and he gave
it to somebody else in the program which
was crippling for me at the time
and I continue to work for Vanguard but
I immediately put my resume out you know
I was like nope not doing this again and
I looked for the opposite of Vanguard
which was Goldman Sachs it's like where
is there a place that couldn't be more
of a meritocracy uh anywhere else in the
world and it was Goldman and that was
right pre-crisis so I didn't know the
world was about to end and I was going
to go to the place that everybody hated
but that's what I ended up doing and I
did I don't know 12 or 15 interviews to
get into Goldman and then ended up
becoming one of their youngest analysts
which was cool female analysts and um
and I went and moved there the
interesting part is like maybe seven
years or eight years later I ended up
the woman who took that job uh that I
created ended up coming to work for me
was my co at my company two companies
ago and uh and then when I exited that
company she became the CEO so yeah so it
worked out great and uh and then I you
know and and I had some like vengeful
feelings for the manager for some time
um
but then I realized man the reason that
I am where I am at in the world and he
is where he's at in the world which are
very different places are because of
your ability to lean in and do the right
thing like what he should have done as a
manager is like coached me through that
and explained how we could get the job
and figure it out whatever and instead
he crippled to other people's pressure
which is what happens at corporations so
now he's still a middle manager at
Vanguard and I'm wherever I am now and I
think that's because you have to make
the hard choices and um and thankfully
he gave me an opportunity to do that
one of the things that we've been we've
been talking a lot about recently
internally within our team is kind of
women in the workplace yeah and
unconscious biases and all and all this
stuff and I recently read lean in by
show us handbook which I thought was
really good
um
if someone is listening to this who
either is a woman in the workplace or is
working with women in the workplace
workplace what advice would you would
you share based on your experiences
well
um
a couple things
first and foremost
choose being the Victor over being the
victim always
and I found it to be a huge benefit that
I'm a woman in the workplace huge
because I look different than everybody
else especially in finance I'm much more
memorable
um you know I have a different way to
engage with people and so I liked
Cheryl's book a lot too and I like this
idea of like
you know I don't know what if you change
the story what if your story is not the
man's out to get me and men are XYZ and
we have this conflict in the workforce
what if it the story is instead I'm
incredibly powerful as a woman uh I look
a little different than everybody else
and because of that I'm gonna have a
massive success and what if all these
men could be my Advocates one of my
mentors told me something that I thought
was kind of kind of true he's like the
men that work with you typically either
want to they want to Father you
they want to friend you oh they want to
[__] you right there's like three types
and you've got to figure out pretty
quickly which one of those three they
fall into and then you use that to your
advantage and you know I did that pretty
specifically if there's a guy who wants
to Father you that's amazing that's a
mentor figure right and you can lean
into that you know feeling of like oh my
daughter or you know I want to help a
young woman get along great if they want
to be friends with you then great you
know you work that angle and the third
are the ones you have to be careful of
but there's also power in that too and I
think a lot of people today we want to
like kill our sexuality in the workforce
and I don't really think that's
necessary actually I think you can be
you can flirt you know you can use the
natural chemistry that happens between
men and women to your advantage and you
can do it in a way that's ethical and
you can do it in a way that's moral and
you can do it within your own personal
code and the code of the company
um but don't wrap up your power I mean I
remember when I first started at
Vanguard I cut my hair really short I
have a lot of hair so I just looks like
a mushroom you know it's not good for
anybody involved and I barely wore any
makeup and I worried like awful boxy
suits and I thought that I had to like
become a man to get into the workforce
and it could have been more opposite you
know I could have been exactly who I
wanted to be
um and that probably would have been
more powerful but it was a lesson I had
to learn
now that I guess you're
you're you know running all these
companies investing all these businesses
yeah how does being a woman feed into
that if at all does it change your
approach compared to if you were let's
say hormuzy for example uh yeah I mean I
think
I think as a woman there are some
truisms like
I try to smile a little bit more it you
know I can come off as a little
aggressive or too intimidating as a
woman so for instance we have the sign
in my studio which is kind of funny that
just says smile [__] really big like
right in front of the camera because I
get serious and I think about it and
then I realize oh my God in all my
videos it's like I'm yelling at
everybody all the time and so um I do
think that we have to be honest about
where we came from as men and women and
our Natural Evolution which is we were
often thought of as nurturing it's not
as normalized for women to be aggressive
and you know whatever we and so lead
into that as opposed to be pissed off
about it because the world doesn't care
either way and so why would you be mad
about something that will have no effect
um and so now I think
you know for instance if I was going to
buy your business Ollie and I was a man
I might buddy up to you you know we'd go
to the 19th hole and play some golf we
might smoke a cigar we'd hang out and do
Harry Pottery things like you would have
like a natural thing you're comfortable
doing with men and when I'm a woman I
have to come at it from a little bit
different of an angle so instead of
doing that I might
I might I might reach out to you and do
something in like the safe zone right so
like coffee or lunch but I would be fun
about it I'd be like tell me about you
like what's going on that's cool what
are you wearing like I'd make jokes I'd
um I kind of feel more familiar than I
think at Alex hermosi if you've met Alex
he's kind of like yes great you know
what he's big and he's actually got a
great sense of humor but his that would
not be great coming from me you would be
like she doesn't really like me what's
happening there that would be a weird
interaction yeah and so recognizing that
it's not flirting but it's it's like
familial right
um and so I find with owners especially
most owners are 65 plus years old so
they're of a different generation right
and so my conversations with them end up
falling often into the father category
so it's like you know tell me about your
history like who how many years have you
been running this 40 that's incredible
like what was the moment like when you
open it up when was the last time that
you almost felt like you had to give up
on this business because it was so
miserable did you ever go bankrupt like
and so being really curious with them I
think as a woman you can do and if you
did that as a man often it's almost hard
you're like no I've never gone bankrupt
you got bankrupt you know so like use
your ability as a female to to be more
empathetic nice love it this is a great
advice
um so you joined Goldman yeah and what
was the story at Golden socks go I
actually loved Goldman in a lot of ways
um Goldman has an incredible culture
because they know who they are and they
attract the people that they should and
they what's the opposite of track they
repel those that should not be there and
I think that is a hack in business I'm
sure you found it uh with employees too
you kind of know an archetype of it's I
don't mean gender or race or any of that
I mean the thinking of a human that will
fit well in ali abdom
um you know you need somebody that you
can trust in your home right you need
somebody that has like a kind of a
kindness to them you probably couldn't
have somebody that was really sharp
elbows in here blowing everybody around
right if they only wanted to wear suits
they're not going to fit for you and so
you have to actually repel the people
that would be miserable at your job and
uh and Goldman's great at that and so I
really liked gold Med for that reason
they cut 20 of the workforce every year
so that's oh that's hard wow okay yeah
um so every year you would I mean every
day at that place I think I didn't see
the Sun for like seven months because I
started in Chicago and so you would get
in the office at seven You'd Stay you'd
work out at the office you'd eat at the
office and it was an incredibly intense
culture
um but I learned so much from it one of
my favorite Frameworks from
Goldman that I took is you know
basically uh they have a couple
different levels of humans at Goldman
but when you're an analyst you're you're
doing everything right there's no no is
not in your vocabulary at that level and
um and I had a a boss uh James Yount who
um was very intense former military and
he came in one day and uh gave gave me a
few minutes you know when he was walking
into the office because I was one of the
first people in and he doesn't usually
give anybody a few minutes that's very
rare and so I said to him hey I'm new
you know 30 seconds can I walk you to
your office yeah sure great said uh I'm
new uh I don't have a crazy background I
didn't go to Cambridge or whatever
you're sort of similar you seem like you
really pulled up yourself by your
bootstraps like two or three things that
you think I could do in the first 30
days to differentiate myself anything
and he was like no it's one thing like
okay great he's like be here earlier
stay later that's it
and I was like really okay so I just did
that for a year I was just in before
anybody else and I stayed later than
anybody else and I got promoted faster
than anybody else and I made more money
faster than anybody else and so um what
I liked about Goldman is they told you
and it was just like how much pain can
you tolerate and that tolerating pain
for a period up front led to a lifetime
of now I don't have to tolerate much
pain at all like we get to do this
during the day I have a full staff you
know I get to hang out a lot you know we
make YouTubes like what a what a it's
unbelievable that we make money doing
this and that was because I I took I
took a lot of pain early
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by heal I've been using hula I've
been a pain customer of huel since 2017
since my fifth year of medical school
when I first discovered it and basically
what it is if you haven't heard of it is
that it is a meal in a shake it got the
perfect balance of carbs and fiber and
proteins and fat and it contains 26
different vitamins and minerals all you
do is add water or milk to the powder
usually I use water you can shake it up
or you can blend it I prefer to blend
and then it becomes a fantastic option
if you're like me and you're kind of
busy and so you don't really have time
for breakfast or lunch my favorite
version is the heel black edition it's
absolutely sick 400 calories 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and it's actually pretty hard
to find something that has such a high
protein content for such a low calorie
trade-off and so I really like using the
heel black edition to start my mornings
off it's vegan it's gluten-free it's
lactose free the Black Edition is
available in nine flavors my favorite is
salted caramel and I wouldn't recommend
having every single meal heal because
that gets a bit annoying after a while
but it's absolutely fantastic it's like
one of the meals of the day especially
if you're busy and you're gonna kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to one pound 68 per meal for a
400 calorie meal which is just
incredible value and actually way
cheaper than other generic protein
shakes on the market and it saves a
bunch of time because it's so quick and
easy to make and so it's particularly
exciting that they're sponsoring the
podcast and actually we had the founder
of huel Julian Hearn who was on the very
first season of the podcast that was a
sick episode that got so many rave
reviews as well anyway if you're
interested in trying out huel then head
over to huel.com forward slash Deep dive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heel.com
forward slash Deep dive that'll also be
linked down in the video description or
the show notes and thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you can invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started when investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode do you think it's uh necessary
to take that pain early or if in a in an
alternative or in an alternate universe
could you have enjoyed that process
while also getting all the benefits from
it question like I I think I did enjoy
the process I think I learned to love
pain and struggle and uh and there were
the only thing that was the hard for me
is being really really tired I can see
that why that's a torture tactic because
there were days where you had to focus
and I would be like
you know I'm like I'm barely here right
now
um that was really tough but actually
the long hours working on an interesting
problem set is is not a problem but I
think it is a and I was just thinking
about this this week I had a tough week
this week stuff going on in the
companies lots of work no sleeping and
um and I was writing about reminding
myself why do I keep doing this I don't
technically I need to keep doing this
you probably don't technically need to
keep doing this so why and the reason is
because I think that the struggle is a
bit of an honor and I think if you want
to know what the key to happiness is
it's struggle if you want to know what
the key to wealth is it's struggle if
you want to know what the the key to
making a lot of money is it's struggle
and the more that that you can realize
that iron actually does sharpen iron and
the more sort of difficult things you
can champion and do the more likely you
are to have a successful life
um I I think it's a life hack it's a
secret that these days we don't want to
hear now everybody wants you know I want
to do the least and make the most I want
to hire the least amount of people and
have the biggest company I'm a solo
entrepreneur that will never employ
anybody that makes millions on the
internet and you can do it too without
any work of four hours a week like
that's the thing that we've said we want
and then I think about it for a second I
stand back and I'm like is that really
what we want like what happened to
billion Empires what happened to leaving
legacies what are you going to do in the
other 52 hours of your week and so I
don't think you have to struggle forever
but I think periods of struggle make the
periods of relaxation really poignant
and with one without the other is like a
day without a night
nobody wants to live in a complete
pleasure and happiness always because it
diminishes and so I do think you need it
I mean what do you think because you
went through worse sleep deprivation in
medical school than I did yeah this is
the thing that I'm not sure about like
um I've been looking a lot into this in
the process of writing my book
um where
you know there's that quote from
Muhammad Ali which is
um you know I thought about quitting but
I said you know don't quit suffer now
and live the rest of your life as a
champion and this whole thing of like I
suffered for 10 years and then it was
worth it at the end of it because I held
up a trophy kind of vibe yeah and that
has never really sit right with me
because
if you know when when I was when I was
when I was talking to to Alexi he's he
said something which I I think about
quite a lot which is that
you know when I when I was when I was 20
I would have given everything to be a
millionaire and when I was a millionaire
I would have given everything to be 20
again
and so usually I feel like these periods
of struggle When We're Young in
particular like
like if we look at
the regrets of the dying on the on the
deathbed basically everyone says I wish
I hadn't worked so hard and I think for
people who are very driven
there is a kind of a default tendency to
over invest in work and under invest in
relationships and health and I know a
few people for whom that has screwed
them up because they've gotten to their
let's say mid-30s 40s whatever they've
chased the corporate ladder or success
in entrepreneurship or whatever they
might think that thing might be their
whole life and then they look around and
they're like oh crap all my friends are
married with kids and I and I've just
been chasing chasing the green dollars
yeah and I I wonder if
like the way I've always tried to
approach it is you know when I was going
through med school building YouTube
channel working as a doctor it was
always around how can I make this
process enjoyable and energizing for
myself so that it doesn't feel as if I
am struggling or grinding and stuff yeah
and maybe that's that kind of millennial
like wanting to have their cake and
either two kind of situation but when
you said
when you said struggle is happiness
that's where I was like oh I'm not sure
I I would venture that balance is
happiness and
there are periods of struggle certainly
because growth comes from struggle
almost certainly but then there's the
other side of it which is
and happiness comes from you know having
friends to hang out with and taking care
of your health and all those things as
well so yeah yeah I've yeah what do you
what do you think well I think you're
right I think it's important not to
assume that struggle can only be in work
so I think you're right about that we
talk about something called a third
degree human basically like a third
degree black belt and so we have a
triadic contrarian thinking that's
civilized the Mind makes Savage the body
build the bank account so the idea is
the civilize the Mind makes Savage the
body is an ancient Chinese proverb
translated but basically that yeah you
want to how do you civilize the mind you
read incredible things right you have
interesting conversations you question
things you struggle with that voice
inside of your head that's always
telling you negative perceptions right
and you try to not tame the beast but
understand it and that's like one type
of struggle right and then you have make
Savage the body which is a different
type of struggle it's like the struggle
to
eat well you know the the J like I don't
know like do you find Joy I find a lot
of joy in an incredibly hard workout
like a yoga session where you're just
dripping sweat but the music's
incredibly difficult and I so maybe
there are different types of humans too
but I find that when I kind of take it
to the edge that there's this there's
Beauty in it there's like Beauty in
how far can you push your body you know
how far can you push your mind how much
can you create yeah and then maybe that
is where happiness kind of strides the
bigger issue I think I see today is that
so many people
so many people seem like they don't have
a purpose anymore and like We're a
nation of people who their deathbed they
say that because they chose a job
because of outside mimetic reasons that
they stuck with for 10 or 20 or 30 or 40
years or they looked for Fast Cash and
fast rewards and never found it as
opposed to
I don't know about you but I get so lost
in the moments where I'm doing the thing
I should be doing you know when I'm
writing really deeply when I'm thinking
really deeply when I'm having an
engaging conversation but I'm struck
like even right now I'm like I'm
struggling to think of how do I say this
exactly but there's like I'm finding it
very interesting you know it would not
be interesting us talking about the
weather which would be super easy us
watching a Mindless TV show that is so
uninteresting to me so maybe we need a
better better definition of struggle
yeah yeah I think that's it because uh
yeah as you were describing that um the
whole you know shopping the mind of the
body thing
I think
it's like one one example I often think
of is you know during lockdown I got a
PS5 I started to play Horizon zero Dawn
and I switched it to very hard
difficulty it wasn't quite Ultra hard
which is just a bit torturous but very
hard was like a good sweet spot yeah
where my housemate would see me just
like trying to clear the same Bandit
camp for about three hours because it
was on very hard difficulty and you had
to get the right like headshot to make
sure that they're new to you and all
this kind of stuff and at the end of it
would be like oh yes I'm glad I spent
the last three hours on very hard
difficulty yeah I could have breezed
through it in five seconds on story mode
difficulty but like what what would be
the point of that like exactly that
there is joy to be found in the
challenge itself
but at the same time if
that's I think where the where where I
think about this idea of balance
you know that's three hours from like I
don't know eight to eleven PM while it's
locked down but you know if that was
four hours five hours six hours seven
hours and the rest of my life is
suffering now I might be struggling on
very hard difficulty on our Horizon zero
Dawn or even Ultra hard but I'm unlikely
to be particularly happy because the
rest of life is not quite in Balance
totally and so I kind of think of it as
these moments of moments of challenge
you know in the in the book we we've got
a chapter around play like if you can
find a way to approach your work in the
spirit of play which is often with a
sense of wonder and curiosity but a
decent sprinkle of challenge as well
yeah that's what makes it fun and that's
kind of been my Approach for well since
Medical School how do I take this
Challenge and find a way to make it fun
or if I'm doing something really boring
how do I apply a challenge to it to make
it more fun than it currently is so yeah
I totally agree I mean I think I think
we forget sometimes that most humans if
you go to ask it's one of my favorite
games they do it a lot to Uber drivers
like uh I'll say something like
you know what what was your day like
today like what did you I just want to
see a different perspective so here in
London I think that's interesting like
how many hours you've been driving
what's going on and then I like to ask
them when was the last time that you did
something so hard you could barely stand
it and the reason I like to ask that is
because every time I ask myself that I
realize oh shoot it's been a little bit
hard longer than I anticipated you know
when was the last time you stayed up all
night working on something because you
couldn't help but do it right and when
you ask yourself that question then it
makes you push yourself slightly to find
those things and in moments where I
haven't done that in six months let's
say I realize ugh I have been grinding
I've not been struggling I've just been
sort of on a low level grind which I
think is soul killing and oftentimes
they'll tell me something really
interesting like I just had a baby you
know three months ago and I I never
thought I could survive in that moment
what was happening and that was that was
really cool there's actually this great
book called The Men the mission and me
it's about uh a Green Beret so special
forces in the U.S and and he has a line
in there that basically says there is
nothing more motivating than a mission
you're unsure you can solve and uh I
think I think that's why we're put here
as humans
um
but who knows at the end of the day
might just make me feel better on long
nights so you you said
one of the well one of the problems
might be that people don't don't have a
purpose
um what's what's your purpose what's the
thing that's driving you to do all the
stuff yeah a couple things one time you
know I think it's really useful if
you're wondering what your purpose is if
you're struggling with am I doing the
right thing day in and day out
I like to think about a tombstone and
mine and I remember one time I had a
crazy dream and in the dream I basically
walked in the cemetery as one does and
my Tombstone came up in front of me and
at the time I was in private equity and
it just said like managing director Cody
Sanchez and I was like oh gross
what that's gonna be the Legacy I'm like
a managing director and a private Equity
Firm kill me and so I think sort of
looking at your Tombstone and it doesn't
have to be work related it could be you
know father that might be an incredible
thing to have a new Tombstone right and
so uh that made me change my perspective
and now I hope the legacy is that we
bring more humans into ownership that's
the second deal I'm playing idea I'm
playing around with which is I think
more humans need skin in the game uh in
some way shape or form it's the only way
to feel like you have
you have ownership in this world you
have something that you are striving for
and building and most people rent their
Apartments these days or their houses
most people work at jobs where they
don't have equity in it only 15 percent
of humans actually own stocks which
would be equity in companies by and
large we're becoming a nation or a world
of renters when we started you know over
the last century just finally becoming
owners after years of serfdom and so
um that is my mission is I want more
human beings to have their little their
little plot of land figuratively or
physically because I think that that
changes the way we look at the world
then we start to become stewards of it
then we start become stewards of our
country you don't burn down the building
that you own right you fix it you
renovate it you build on it so that's
what I hope our mission is I hope when
I'm dead I hope there's a bunch of
people that would never have owned
anything and now own something and they
get to pass that on to the next
Generation because otherwise just the
guys at the top own everything I mean
one out of four houses last year got by
three companies in the U.S single family
houses we don't even own our homes
anymore and so that I think needs to
change so how much is that the thing
that drives you versus uh you know I
struggle with this myself figuring out
is it purpose or is it actually money or
status or power that are the other or
the likes on the Instagrams yeah which
we have status and I can convince myself
that yeah you know there's likes on
Instagram it's important for my
parasource relationship with my audience
which translates to bottom line profit
but like you know who am I kidding I
sometimes ask myself
I mean I think it's easy to
guys are just you know they're the the
Milestones on a map right that get you
to a final destination and so a kpi
would be something like likes on your
Instagram or social media followers it's
very easy for me to get caught up in the
daily or weekly numbers because I'm a
numbers person and so I have to be
really really careful that I zoom out we
do something every week at my company
called the weekly WhatsApp and basically
I zoom out for a 10 minute segment of
our our company meeting where I will
talk about something really high level
so I'll share a quote from Like A Book
Like Jocko willinks about the honor of
leadership and how it sucks to be a
leader but it's also incredible
um and then I'll talk about a
testimonial from somebody who who we
helped and so we'll highlight that and
maybe that testimonial is about like
somebody specifically on the team so I
try to zoom out once a week but for sure
I think you know at the end of the day
we're selfish self-interested beings
that are try trying to continue to
survive
um you know if you look at Evolution
like that we need to procreate and we
need to survive a certain amount of time
so I think you have to rewire your brain
a little bit to not just only focus on
you but there's no doubt about it I mean
I like the ego of it uh I think it's
super fun seeing our videos go viral I
think it's super fun making money it's a
giant scoreboard and I think that's what
money is at the end of the day the rich
I don't think continue to do things for
the money the rich do things because
it's a game and they want to win on the
scoreboard
um
that's my take for now there's a there's
a book I've been reading uh was a
studded reading called I think it's
called the road to character
um where by David Brooks I think what he
talks about I like David
um like there are resume virtues and
then there are eulogy virtues the things
that you would write on your resume and
then they're the things that people will
tell you would say at your funeral
and his argument in the book seems to be
that the money stuff tends to be not the
thing that people would say at your
funeral
um so how do you think about this ballot
like again I'm asking because this is
something that I genuinely think about
every day like this this balance between
striving for the numbers to go up versus
I don't know the other things that make
up a a holistic and well-lived life yeah
well my husband and I do
um we do bi-annual bucket list trips and
those are typically something difficult
so we're going to for instance
um go to Mongolia uh on Horseback uh for
12 days and we want to meet with this
one tribe A friend of ours it's one of
the last tribes that rides reindeers
like caribus in Mongolia and so we're
going to do a thing that's perceivably
hard we're going to do it together which
I think is really important and
um and I think once when we do like one
or two of those kind of things a year so
I hiked you know Mount Baker we're also
going to go do this Exploration with
whale sharks with a friend of mine who
does National Geographic whale shark
tagging and I imagine uh that if
somebody was to give a eulogy of us at
some point there will be hopefully that
we're 70 80 years old doing bizarre
things like that
um and so I think I don't know how to
live a really sporadic spontaneous life
like I get so wrapped up at work and
doing The Daily Grind maybe like a lot
of people do it's hard for me to go do
the the wild things continuously so
there's a very simple thing that seems
to work for me which is just I sort of
schedule the ridiculous and that sounds
like you shouldn't do it but you know
some of my favorite stories to write or
or read about are like Ernest Shackleton
right like best oh so good he wrote the
best job description of all time which
was but you've definitely seen it it's a
little paper cut out and it basically
says
um
men needed for a Dangerous Mission and
it says things like uh survival unlikely
return questionable you know pain
absolute and he received thousands of
people that applied for this job and I
think the reason is because we want that
crazy mission right like we want to be
the Indiana Jones in the next film in
some way shape or form and so
um I don't know how to live a big huge
life except to have experiences and so
so I don't know do you do anything like
that where you try to go on one or two
Wild Adventures a year
less so wild adventures but more so I'm
I'm also a big fan of scheduling the
bucket list items yeah but my version of
a world Adventure was I was like oh it's
on the bucket list to go on a fishing
trip so I went on a fishing trip two
weeks ago and that was very nice yeah I
love that um but it's not it's not been
as wild what do you want on your eulogy
I think uh I also I also thought about
the the the tombstone thing a couple
years ago and I landed on good father
good husband and inspirational teacher
and I realized that for me if I could
teach people that's a thing that I think
I would I would love to be able to say
it at my funeral yeah it was a nice guy
and all that nice just family and
friends blah blah but like
yeah helped
you know if
if I could have the sort of impact on
someone that Tim Ferriss had on me
through his stuff where it nudged me on
a completely different kind of life path
that I would have been otherwise then I
think that would be pretty sick like if
someone leaves their job to start a
business because they Vibe my stuff or
someone starts a YouTube channel that
takes off because they've opened my
stuff like you know things like that or
even someone you know does better in
their exams because they've opened my
stuff and that helps them kind of live
their dreams that to me is like the
thing that I want to do for now yeah so
wait I have two questions one do you
care if people perceive you as a nice
guy
is that important to you yeah why
oh good question why
why is it important that people perceive
me as a nice guy
probably because I have a fundamental
need to be liked and admired and
appreciated and stuff yeah interesting
yeah
yeah I always I like to double tap on
the nice thing because I think
I think it's lovely to want to be nice
because a world full of [__] doesn't
sound good for anybody nobody wants that
but I've always rather been I would
rather be respected than liked I would
rather
um my best teachers weren't just nice
right they like push you a little bit
which maybe you could do in a nice way
so I'm always curious if people now it's
hard to not always be perceived as nice
because you get a lot of pushback on it
and maybe it's a story I'm telling
myself too but I'm always curious on
that idea of nice and doesn't really
matter
um maybe you could be kind
but but you have to be nice yeah but I
think by nice I mean I mean kind rather
than like nice has a lot of like other
things brought up in like being a
doormat and all that kind of stuff
that's associated with this
but yeah when I say nice I mean it as
like a just a sum of like kind good
person yeah thoughtful desperate kind of
stuff yeah like I mean I could work on
on all those things more for sure
it's pretty nice
um I also was hugely influenced by Tim
Ferriss we're actually in the same group
chat with him and I remember when when
you know our mutual friends three put
put us into that put me into that group
chat and I saw that Tim was in it I was
like I went and texted him I'm like I'm
not gonna do anything weird but I am so
excited because Tim Ferriss was I think
one of the first people for a lot of us
that made us feel like we could actually
architect Our Lives yeah you know nobody
told me that before Tim yeah everybody
was like no no here's how you do it you
wear the suit you do the thing and then
I think he was the first one it wasn't
necessarily that I only wanted to work
four hours it was like oh wait but I
could choose uh so I think that's
incredible and so I think the other
thing to ponder too which I think about
too is what do you want to become
known for and also doesn't matter
because at the end of the day will be
dust completely unremembered just like
the greatest Emperors of all time so I
mean you can't even remember the last
name of most of the greatest people who
ever ruled the planet
um and so at some point I think perhaps
none of it matters but do it anyway yeah
plus finding yeah I I kind of think
um in a funding finding joy in the
journey yeah um and having a destination
in mind short but recognizing that like
you know from all of the people I spoke
to all the stuff I read it's just like
no one ever finds happiness at the end
of The Journey they find it on Route and
so great let's try and you know coming
back to that point of enjoy the enjoy
the present day while we're working
towards that destination I agree totally
um so we're in Goldman Sachs right now
what what happened next in in the career
yeah so after Goldman
um well basically so I was I'm divorced
and remarried uh but at that time I was
dating somebody at Goldman and he was
leaving to go to a job in Dallas so I
wanted to really continue the investment
banking thing and go to New York and go
International
um but he was moving and so I ended up
moving with him which maybe is one of
the things I regret at some point but it
ended up working out so I was leaving
Goldman the only option at Gold Medal
that's right can I just double check
uprooting your life for the sake of a
relationship yeah what are your thoughts
well I have a bias there right because
it didn't work out great
um so take that with a grain of salt but
I think more important if you uproot
your life for somebody into another life
that you want to live incredible but I
think be really careful about uprooting
yourself for another into a life you
don't want to live and so in this
instance I had always wanted to work
internationally and I had wanted to
build big businesses and instead I moved
to Dallas Texas I get a huge house with
the white picket fence and a country
club membership you know poor guy didn't
stand a chance right like that was just
not part of the vision of my future that
I wanted and I think he thought I would
change and I thought that he was okay
with who I was and um and the disconnect
lay in there so now when I think about a
relationship like with my husband now
we're very big on
um what is the vision we both want out
of life it's not just are we compatible
as humans and do we like each other but
do we want the same big things because
if you ollie really want kids and to
live in London and to do XYZ and your
person is tied to Bangladesh and wants
no children then it kind of doesn't
matter how in love the two of you are
because the lives that you want will
continue to pull at the seams
um and so I think be really cautious
about this idea of you know I'm just
really compatible and I'll drop
everything for this other human which
leads to resentment at least it did for
me
um so I wouldn't do that again okay and
yet I've moved many times for my husband
and we go through Cycles so we'll talk
about them like for this for the three
year period we're in right now this is
my cycle you know I'm building this
business that requires a lot of travel
he travels with me often and we're
building it together for the three-year
cycle prior he was in the military and
so we had to be based wherever he was
based
um and so we had this vision of the
future that was combined and even now we
work a lot and we we try to not use the
word sacrifice ever we say like we make
decisions or we prioritize
um and we prioritize for the ultimate
Vision which is we want to live this big
life and leave this big Empire behind us
and we want to build something so big
that our kids can come into it I'm
hiring my father now I hire a bunch of
my friends into the business and I want
to fold our work and our life into one
so we're willing to do things to achieve
that
so you moved to Dallas what happened
next so I moved to Dallas and then if
you are listening for instance and you
want a job really bad maybe this is a
case study for you so at that time I was
at Goldman and
um I wasn't that high up I think I was
an associate at the time and so I wanted
to go and run a bigger company and I
wanted to do it inside the investment
realm and largely I wanted to do it in
what's called institutional so I wanted
to sell to big companies pensions
Sovereign wealth funds whatever and to
get that job basically uh I had to I had
to fly to three different continents to
interview on my own dime
um I got to know every single hiring
manager at this company called State
Street I sent like a custom ball signed
because I figured out the manager really
liked this one baseball player I
basically I like smothered them I just
smothered them to a point which the guy
finally was just like Jesus Christ like
okay fine we'll hire you for something
it's not exactly what you wanted but
we'll hire you but I got turned down
something like four or five times by
this company for a ton of different
roles but I think what people don't
realize
is relentless persistence is so rare
that if you really want a particular job
in a particular Company If You Can
relentlessly pursue it in a way that
feels a little uncomfortable yeah um
that would be inappropriate and
borderline stocking if you were to do it
to a significant other you can largely
get it and so I got this job at State
Street where I headed up one segment of
the country and I was selling
Investments cash Investments to big
companies and then uh I left there to go
to a company called first oh no no I
wanted to leave there to go to Credit
Suisse which these days maybe not so
much but in fact then it was good and uh
and I did the same thing I basically
applied for this job flying to New York
and I flew to London to meet with them I
flew to San Francisco and I got turned
down twice for the job I got really
really close and then they said no and
then I got really really close again and
they said no and gave it to another
woman but the third time they came back
to me and they offered me the job and at
that point I was like nope because I got
another one at this company called First
Trust but I have never just been given
or offered the job or just given or
offered the opportunity it's always been
it's always been relatively painful and
so I think if a lot of people could take
more permission in the fact that we
think that that's okay in
entrepreneurship these days like yes
just keep going for the clients keep
getting after it but if you want a
traditional job too you will be in I
mean I was making millions of dollars a
year uh with no risk because I was doing
it on a company time traveling around
the world learning and engaging with
presidents of countries
um and and I was able to do it because
nobody else was that Relentless in their
Pursuit I was much too young to have
that job yeah
yeah this is something that
um you know in lean in he calls us
something about like uh Tiara complex or
something like that where
um in particular apparently women in the
workplace feel like if I just put my
head down and do a good job someone will
put a TR on my head and will give me a
promotion and what she says in the book
is that like
it would be amazing if that were to
happen in in the real world no one has
any time and everyone is like just doing
a zillion different things so you have
to you have to put yourself out there
um and it sounds like that's like sort
of to an insane degree that's what you
did yes I like the idea of the Tierra
complex I think it's a fine line you
know these days uh people will say
things like always ask for what you want
you need to temper the always asking the
way that I asked made it a win-win for
everybody right I would find problems
within the companies and say I think I
can solve this for you you know what are
you paying somebody right now pay me
half like I was always trying to give
them such a win that a no would feel
wrong yeah like a grand slam offer right
yeah and uh and that I think is what is
missing from a lot of the asks today you
must get them too I get DMS constantly
can I learn from you can I do this
they're very sweet but they're very
selfish actually and so if you wanted to
do a good ask it would have to be
something where you have obsessed on
that person so much you know so much
about them that the thing you're going
to offer is so valuable that they would
be crazy not to take you up on it
um and we actually we have a YouTube
video that's coming out I wonder if
it'll be out by then maybe Christian's
back there
um and it's about it's about this we
basically came up with this idea of we
think that you know you're one degree
away from basically almost any mentoring
want in the world and that they are much
easier to get than you could ever
imagine just everybody does it wrong
because they take a shotgun approach
right so it's DM DM DM DM DM DM low
level
unspecific
non-tailored non-value-added Outreach
and they wonder why it doesn't work
when you want to get a high value Target
what do you do do you ever shoot it at
them with a shotgun no you have a sniper
rifle you spend a ton of time on the
preparation for it it's called prepping
the environment
and you would want to make sure that the
wind direction is correct you want to
make sure the sun is correct and it's
the same thing I think when you want
something out of life including
mentorship and so in this instance we
basically showed three different ways
that we take an idea to get in front of
somebody and we make it a reality and we
actually got Christian in front of like
somebody that he looks up to a big
podcaster and um and we did it without
money and we did it without networks and
they had to reach out independently so
it is much easier than ever to get a
mentor you just have to treat it like a
sniper rifle never like a shotgun what
do you mean by Mentor yeah that's a good
question I don't like that word that
much but
I think most of the mentors in your life
come from like one small engagement
right you sit next to somebody on a
Plane by accident I meet you somewhere
randomly we started engaging in DMS on
the internet right and now I learn from
you actually on many different things
and so right and so and how did it start
it was really low level so I think it's
it's a bit like
um it's like a Tinder swipe right or a
bumble swipe you start by just like oh
yep I'm gonna swipe left on you I'm
gonna make a very small engagement that
might be at a conference I'm going to
walk up to Ali abda I'm going to
introduce myself and I'm going to say hi
I'm Cody Sanchez I love your stuff I'm
going to DM you I think something might
be interesting for you later and you'd
go okay whatever cool thanks nice to
meet you that's your Tinder swipe you've
shown engagement then your second level
is going to be when you reach out to
them it should be something really
value-added with no ask hey ali uh I saw
that you have these videos coming up I
pulled the top 10 best uh performing
videos for small accounts but huge viral
videos and I just said it to you here I
hope it's interesting you'd be like oh
great thanks and then you have a tiny
opening and then you basically are like
opening the window opening the window
opening the window until finally you
have a relationship and then the
relationship can become a mentorship but
it starts with actually you giving
something to that person
um and I think there's very easy ways to
do that but people don't want to spend
that much time on one person because
they're scared what if Ollie who I look
up to so much and I try to do this thing
and then it doesn't work but that's a
terrible way to think about it it's what
if I could give Ollie some value and
wouldn't that be incredible for all the
value he gave for me if you do that a
couple different times one of them will
eventually return it but you don't have
the expectation yeah why do you think
people get this so wrong it's easy you
know it's so easy to do the little DM
Outreach and it's scary I really give
people credit for that you know
sometimes I like to ask when I meet like
famous people
um and and I know they know another
famous person that I actually really
look up to I'll say like what do you
thick do you really like this person are
they a good good person and the reason
why is because if they're not I don't
really want to meet them I don't want to
have that hero fall from high right I
would rather just read the book learn
this stuff great like if I met Tim
Ferriss and now I've engaged with him
he's a very nice guy but if if I met him
and he was terrible oh that'd be so sad
wouldn't it and I think that's how they
feel about a lot of us they're like what
if I get this thing and I don't didn't
really you know and it doesn't make me
happy uh what if I reach out to ollie
and he's awful to me and so I think it's
scary and people are lazy
so we were um she got this job with
first was it first First Trust First
Trust then how did that end up
transitioning into what you're what
United that was incredible so that the
CEO of that company he hates being on
the Internet so he's not gonna like me
talking about this but he's a he's a
billionaire multiple times over uh it's
an incredible company it was a cult-like
uh atmosphere I actually don't like the
um environment very much it's very broey
Finance you know strippers and whatever
but uh he he himself is probably the
best public speaker I've ever seen and
he did a great thing with me so I met
him early on and I was running a company
at the time that was much bigger like
billions and billions of dollars in
Revenue my division at State Street and
um he was just starting in Latin America
he wanted to grow the Latin America
business and I met him and he's like I
really would like you to come work for
me and I was like like how big is it
what's happening he's like no there's
nothing there I was like Jim you know no
I run this huge thing I don't want to
come over here and build this little
thing for you who are you guys anyways
you're only based in the US no thanks
and he was like I'm gonna tell you
what's gonna happen I was okay it's like
you're gonna say no you're gonna say no
you're gonna say no then you're finally
gonna say yes and it's going to be the
best decision of your life and I was
like it's confident and then we started
engaging but I'll never forget that
you're gonna say no you're gonna say no
you're gonna say no you're going to say
yes and he was right and so
he basically taught me the power of
building a culture which I'm sure you
felt it too before I ran a business I
thought like I would never have read a
book about culture yeah no absolutely
not I would never actually have read a
book about leadership to be honest I
thought like I don't know I'm over here
I don't I don't know and the more money
I've made the more I realize if you can
lead and if you can create culture you
are Limitless if you cannot do those two
things you're very limited and so
actually we should spend all the time on
culture and Leadership there's there's a
great quote that says if you want to if
you need to build a boat do not teach
your men to go and build planks and
build rope teach them instead to yearn
for the vast and Endless Sea right and
it's so true if you want to be a
successful leader you actually need to
teach your people to yearn for the thing
that you want you need to teach them
that the mission of getting three
million followers on social and the
lives are going to change is so big that
they should be thinking about it
non-stop because is the difference
between an individual contributor who
does okay things in life and a leader
is really can you sell a dream so big
you replace somebody else's that's what
it means for somebody to come work for
you a dream so big that it replaces
somebody else's and uh and so that's
what Jim did to me at First Trust he
sold me a dream so big even though at
that moment it was not big it was
nothing that he replaced my current
reality actually and I went to work for
him and I'll never regret that because
despite me not really liking the culture
and a lot of the managers there I
respect the hell out of him because I
learned a lot about there's this line in
Dune have you read Dune oh Ollie you
have to read it I think I'm about three
hours into the audiobook at the moment
oh yeah the audiobook yeah well so
um there's a line in there that says
something about
um like the day is so sweet
um when the sound of your bees hum and
it's one of the dictators and he's
basically talking about at this moment
he has his team of people out searching
for this guy
um but I always like that line because
it makes you realize the full power of
having a hive of people who are out
spreading your gospel or your sermon or
your dream if you actually want to leave
this Legacy of leadership it's not going
to be very big if you just do it by
yourself you have to have these bees
surrounding you out buzzing and so he
taught me that at first stress and I
stayed there for the longest I've ever
stayed at a company five years before I
started my own private Equity Firm one
thing that I was intrigued by was a
tweet thread that you did um in at the
end of 2022 you said after 13 years in
finance and managing hundreds of
millions here are 21 truths that will
make you more money than any business
degree and I wonder if I can just feed
you some of these things and if you can
just Riff on them and we'll just see see
where that takes us
um so number one if no one thinks you're
crazy you're too late
yes true
um actually I have a guy who's become a
mentor of mine his name is Bill Perkins
and he's a sort of a well he wrote die
with zero he's a great guy and uh he
actually reached out to me uh a few
times on the internet and then we
invested in a company together
and so I went to his house and his huge
compound it's beautiful in Austin and
we're walking along the lake
and he sat down with me and he was like
um you know I really respect everything
you're doing the small business stuff is
super interesting he's like but do you
think that you have been around small
for so long that small has infected your
thinking and I was like oh bill that was
tough and and he said you know with the
amount of views that you guys have and
the mission that you guys have you
should be investing in building you
should be bigger than Blackstone that
should be how big your dream is and he
literally texted me I was in I was in
France yesterday and I was working on a
bunch of different stuff and he texted
me he'll text me randomly these little
things but basically it was
um exactly that it was
um if
you're sharing what you're doing and
somebody doesn't roll their eyes or
think you're crazy you're doing it wrong
and uh this was obviously way after I
did that tweet thread but I think he's
right something shifts when you hang out
with billionaires they just have more
zeros and so their aperture is bigger
they realize that a lot more is possible
than you do because they've bended the
the world to their will in a lot of ways
and so
I try to live by that
even though sometimes it's painful
the market isn't saturated your business
just sucks
a lot of these are lessons to myself
um and that one's true I've had multiple
businesses actually we had a product at
contrain thinking called Cash Flow and
um it just wasn't a good product it was
trying to be something to everybody
which makes it nothing to to no one and
uh so if you're struggling in your
business often we say we need more sales
we need more X if only I had attention
but I try to ask myself what if it was
easy what would the product look like
then and when I do that I typically
realize oh I just have the wrong product
or I have the wrong person or I have the
wrong team
um
the right relationships are better
leverage than money
true especially in this day and age I
was um
I was with one of my friends who is a
general partner at Andresen Horowitz and
um I was asking him because we both
invest in startups I was saying well
what should we do with uh our
investments we want to go this way we
want to go that way and we were going
back and forth and I said you know could
we invest a little bit in injuries and
Horowitz so we could learn about it and
and he said something funny to me he's
like money is such a commodity you
couldn't pay me to take yours and I was
like
really I'm like what does that mean he's
like do you know Sequoia only takes
non-profit dollars now one of the
biggest Venture Capital funds in the
world will only take non-profit money
they literally limit the amount of
capital that they have and instead what
matters to them is access which is
really what people mean access and ideas
those are the things that actually move
the world
what do you mean access so you can have
a lot of money right
I know a lot of people that do but I
would rather trade once you've hit a
base level of cash I would spend as much
as possible investing in growing your
skill set and getting access because if
you can get in a room with
if you can get in a room with well
people like like you and some of the
people were talking about before if you
can get in a room with a bunch of
creators and you become friends with
them and you Ali Abdel talk about my
product Bellow water on your podcast
that is worth how many millions of
dollars in ad spend that I probably
wouldn't have but my access to you turns
into millions of dollars because the
economy of today's eyeballs it's
actually not Capital increasingly money
is going to become more commoditized and
attention will be the commodity yeah and
so that's what I mean by access yeah I
was I was I was I was having dinner with
a friend who's
um a very successful author uh and we
were talking about like Book Sales
strategies and all that kind of stuff
and he said you know
the single biggest thing that has ever
moved the needle for my book sales is
random relationships I made like five
years ago and it's just like somebody
made at a conference someone used to
track a friendship with and because
you've had that conversation you now
know the person turns out that person
happens to grow into a massive YouTuber
a massive podcast right now when you
message them saying hey I've got a new
book out they are delighted to make a
video about your book and it just
completely it's that's that's the sort
of thing that you can't actually buy
with cash you buy it with I guess
relationship equity and just just being
generally Pleasant to hang out with and
taking the time to like fly places to
meet people and all that stuff yeah well
I think in this day and age we have a
declining trust with institutions we
don't trust institutions by and large
and we have an increasing trust with
individuals we've become more tribal
than ever and we've become less
institutional than ever and because of
that our relationships with individual
humans are worth more and if you
actually look at the international trust
index which is a real thing you can do
it by varying countries you see overall
countries are declining on their trust
indices and so I think the ability for
you to connect one-on-one with a human
will be one of the few things that
differentiates the fact that AI can now
create an Ali abdal or can create a Cody
Sanchez and we're going to really have
to question the things that we see with
our eyes and only be able to believe the
things we can feel with our hands
at least that's where I could imagine it
goes
nice
growth is the Small Things magnified
uh
I went to another one of my friends
headquarters who runs a very big company
um and uh and I went to the bathroom
I went to go wash my hands as I was
washing and hit my hands in the bathroom
an employee came up and she washed her
hands and then took the paper towel
clean the inside of the sink cleaned the
countertop I thought what a nice
employee that's super nice I was putting
on lipstick or something another person
came in grabbed a paper towel cleaned
the inside of the sink cleaned the
countertop so I stopped this like low
level marketing person and uh and I was
like what are you doing like what what's
going on there why are you cleaning that
all up that way and she was like how you
do anything is how you do everything
right and just kind of like looks at me
like don't you know that and then walks
out and I thought wow I just got
schooled by a low-level marketer and now
my team is so tired of me saying that
I'm sure but the small details really do
turn into the big things and so often in
our life we let them swim slip it
doesn't mean you have to be obsessed
with every detail
um but to create a culture where your
employees who maybe even make minimum
wage actually clean up the sink around
them clean up messes that are not their
own that are not part of their job
description is a superpower and so we're
working on how do we get everybody to
want to clean up the kitchen sink
how do you square that with uh 80 20 We
There are an infinite number of things
to do let's focus on a few needle moving
things cleaning those things is probably
not needle moving so yeah what if it is
though and so I think
um you think about Disney CEO right Bob
Iger famously what did he do every time
he walked into a park
he stopped and he picked up a piece of
trash somewhere he went out of his way
he would pick him a piece of trash and
then he would go throw it in the trash
can now why would Bob Iger do that his
time for doing that is worth infinitely
more than mine because it's a signal in
a world of noise to say we clean up
around here we have such
um respect for this place that we do the
small things and we make sure that we
clean up messes that aren't ours so
you know it goes down to for instance I
had to let somebody go a couple weeks
ago and the reason why I let that person
go is because they sent out an email to
uh people who engage with us and inside
of that email the email was done so
sloppily and
um with a lot of stuff that would be
helpful for us but not the individual
that I realized oh you don't you haven't
accepted our culture which is that we
help humans we don't get helped by
humans and that was a very small thing
theoretically but every time somebody
from my team engages with people in the
real world they're they're one of my
tentacles right they're a representation
of me and so I have to make sure that
when I send out the email it's lovely
it's helpful for another person we're
giving before we're taking and hopefully
you felt that in our engagements and
that's what I want my team to represent
too and so I do think those little
things actually matter now the real
question is you don't have to do
everything so that's the difference so
you don't have to do it all but the
things that you do you should do well
um and that's another thing Bill Perkins
taught me is he was like if you are
focusing on All the Small Things you'll
never do the big things and so how does
that relate to the two that seems like
that would conflict but what it really
means is hire somebody incredibly well
to take care of your travel planning and
to take care of your you know emails in
your inbox but teach them the way to do
it right then you don't have to do it
but if you're going to do something do
it right it's painful and I'm not great
at it all the time believe me my husband
also loves to then say these things back
to me later which is very obnoxious so
be careful what you put out in the
universe
nice
um give free value with zero
expectations and you'll get 10x returns
down the road yeah give give give OS uh
it's it you know you know there's the
law of reciprocity right we humans feel
like we have to give something back if
we are given something and so
um I think if if I could if I could
leave one thing for humans listening it
would be uh give first and be curious
if you could do those two things I think
you'll go so much farther than you could
anticipate a lot of people in this day
and age think that in a world of
scarcity and a lot of people take take
take take
I have a friend actually loose friend
who um he's notorious for uh
asking for introductions and things and
he always ask asking us and in some ways
he's gotten far but he's also gotten
known in our community as a person who
will always ask you for things and so
you be you become very careful about
giving things and asking for him I never
ask for anything from him because I know
it's going to have like this 3s X return
on the other side and that's what you
don't want to have in life it'll get you
quick pretty far but those people always
come back down again yeah
yeah I think about this a lot like the
the ROI on free is way higher than the
ROI on almost anything transactional or
anything paid
um and yeah there are so many instances
in my life where I mean I guess building
a Content business is just basically all
about that yeah um well I mean we have a
mutual friend Alex and him and I talk
about this a lot what do you think the
mafia does first to indoctrinate people
to bring people into the mafia Circle
they give something that's why like the
mob bosses go around and they make sure
you know the kid has food who doesn't
have food on his table and they make
sure the people that they come in they
give them cash up front now that's a
dark side of it but the reason why they
do that is because then when you've
taken something you've taken a favor and
when you've taken a favor you have this
little bit of a debt right and again you
don't want to take it from a dark
perspective but um there's a reason why
that's often how sort of these tribes
and Cults are created is immediately
they give something to you because they
know that they're going to ask you for
something later it's that famous like
one day I'm gonna call you and ask you
for a favor thank right
um and so it's real in the world
your first hundred thousand dollars
comes faster if you earn before you
invest
yeah too many people want to take a
dollar and invest in the stock market
and have a Robin Hood trade do well for
them or a Bitcoin go up or down or an
nft and I think it's completely wrong
you should optimize first we have a
strategy called learn
um which is basically we want you to
focus first on earning money before you
do anything and the reason why is
because you can't uh if you have money
it's always easier to make money rule
number one in order to make money you
have to first do the thing that is
easiest and highest Roi that's typically
not going to be that you put a dollar
into the stock market and it makes you a
hundred thousand dollars but what you
could do is you could negotiate a salary
increase of five to twenty percent each
year or buy annually and you're much
more likely to then be able to invest
that money intelligently but a lot of
people you know instead of first earning
and then learning and then investing
they go invest learn earn and I think
that's the opposite of what we want to
do too many people have seen people make
a lot of money in investing and it's a
long game yeah yeah I think that's so
true it's like uh
uh sometimes I'll I'll get friends
asking me like hey you know you're
you're into investing like what should I
invest my money in and I'm like
hmm the easy answer is S P 500 but yeah
I I think that's not actually the answer
like what's the goal here let's figure
this out and then you know find out that
oh they'd love to become financially
independent or they'd love to have an
extra few thousand dollars a month to
kind of I don't know go on holiday or
whatever thing might be I'm like okay so
if we if we if you continue investing in
the S P 500 you'll get there maybe 30
years from now is that what you want or
like and ultimately what it comes down
to is like increasing your own ability
to earn money whether through investing
in your own business or investing in
your own skills yeah it's just way
higher Roi than the seven percent
returns you'll get by investing in the
top 500 companies in the US 100 the r
require view is infinite the ROI of an
investment is capped
and so I think
you want to invest to beat inflation I
mean that's originally why we have
investing is that the cost you know the
price of money decreases every single
year due to the government and so we
have to have some sort of investing so
that we our money doesn't get eaten in
the way by inflation that's what we
should expect seven to ten percent per
year would be great if we could do that
continuously anything above and beyond
it unless you're actively involved in
the investment which changes the game uh
isn't going to make you rich it's just
going to make you
beat inflation
okay so buying boring businesses buying
the local dry cleaner restaurant Cafe
kind of thing
seems interesting but what sort of
people would you recommend that to I
guess compared to starting your own
business versus investing in the s p
versus buying houses for Real Estate
rental type stuff
how how does that work yes one startup
if you have a dream so big you can't
sleep for the want of it then do that
that should be your startup
if you just want cash flow this is the
path for you I think and here's a couple
thoughts one real estate on average in
the US at least a one rental property
makes about 476 dollars a month in
profit that's not enough yeah yeah so
might make less than that you have to
buy a ton of them and how much cash do
you have to put down an annoying the
huge amount huge amount not to mention
you have giant risks from the loans
um so I think real estate by and large
is a great way to keep wealth and to
invest so that your wealth grows slowly
over time it's not a great way to make
wealth now buying a business is a lot
more work and it's a lot more risk
theoretically because you're building
it's probably not going to burn down you
have insurance anyways and it can't go
to zero very easily business if you do
it wrong theoretically could so there's
pros and cons
but a small business I like owning a
bunch of them especially if you can do
it in things that you want to play in a
little bit like for instance if you're
an accountant I might buy an accounting
firm right why just work in one when you
could own one
um if you
are like me and you're in content and
you actually really like what you do
like I want to spend my time doing this
maybe I buy a laundromat and my mom runs
the laundromat right or maybe I buy a
property management company and my
brother runs that property management
company which is in fact what I've done
and so um I like to do deals like that
where you don't have to be the one
running them it could be your friend
that you know your friend that you've
worked with for a long time wants to
operate one of these companies and you
are just the one putting the deal
together and you want to continue to do
your own thing so it buying a business
is really because one you want the cash
flow and two maybe you want to get
closer to your local community which is
big for me
what advice would you give to 16 year
old Cody who maybe she's she's got a
thousand dollars through mowing the lawn
and through tutoring maths or something
and she's got a thousand dollars and
she's like I want to invest this
thousand dollars how would you approach
that conversation with your young
younger self
well I'll tell you what I tell my
cousins now we're right about that age
so to my 16 18 year old cousins I say
take the big risk now while you have no
responsibility the more responsibility
you get the scarier the risk becomes
when you have kids when you have a
mortgage when you have a big paycheck
that you could lose it's scary to go
start a business to think about buying a
business to think about being the
operator in a business
but when you're young you should take
all the risk humanly possible because
failure doesn't really matter when
you're young I don't think you should
take a thousand dollars and invest it in
anything when you're young unless you're
investing it in yourself or you're
investing in a big risk like trying to
potentially turn a thousand dollars into
a hundred thousand dollar business
purchase interesting but not Bitcoin or
NFL no no no no I mean there's uh in
investing we say um
we say that those people are speculators
not investors and there's a whole
generation of people that have been
taught speculation not investing anytime
you have the last man fallacy which is
that the person who comes in next that
you're going to sell to is the one is
the dumb one that's going to be holding
the bag you should know that you should
run away from that because you're the
last man we don't want to be a nation of
people who are trying to kind of dupe
people into being the next person to buy
it at a higher valuation than we did we
want to have assets that are so good
that you think like Warren Buffett and
you want to hold them for 30 years you
have to pry that business out of my cold
dead hands because it's a great business
and I think because we had that fast
money run of nfts and Bitcoin and stocks
people get confused and you know the
other thing that's that's so true is
really good Finance people who trade
stocks have something called a black box
they don't even tell their sales people
that go and rep their product what's
inside of their algorithms it's
firewalled you can't see inside why
because I would never tell somebody my
unfair advantage that everybody else
could go replicate immediately if
trading is the way that I make money so
anybody that teaches trading online is
totally full of it in my opinion because
if they had great secrets they would
never share them they'd just pile as
much money as humanly possible into it
and buy a bunch of Bentleys and so I'm
really cautious on speculators and I'm
really bullish on ownership
so how might said 16 year old said
cousin actually invest that thousand
dollars
you invested in yourself I think you
need to learn at that point you have to
learn then you increase your earnings
then you invest no 16 year old should be
taking their thousand bucks and putting
in the s p in my opinion they will make
so much more money by taking that
thousand bucks and going and learning
how to create a bunch of YouTube videos
or going and learning how to buy
businesses or going and learning how to
talk to people and negotiate whatever
the case may be I would take the
thousand bucks and I would consider it
your little MBA money and I think spend
like that until you can start putting
you can do the S P 500 put in 10 of your
savings in I've done that for a long
long time but that won't make you rich
it'll just potentially be an inflation
yeah
um how do you feel about these days the
balance of you can learn anything for
free on the internet therefore you don't
have to pay for it versus the value of
paying for things
there's a lot of research that supports
the fact that if we do not pay for
things we do not appreciate them it's
why we have products that have costs at
my business because your likelihood to
accomplish something if you put skin in
the game is infinitely higher and so we
actually see it it's fascinating the
more we charge for products the more
likely they are to actually finish and
accomplish them when you get something
for free you tend to not value it right
I mean you think about all the giveaways
at a conference as opposed to something
that you buy and so we give away 90 of
our content for free with the hope that
people will take their own action but if
you actually want to take action put
skin in the game I mean my husband and I
like to do little bets so if I want to
go right now I want a six pack so I'm
working on that so like we'll have a
little bet so we'll have a thousand
bucks in and whoever does X thing
related to Fitness First gets the
thousand bucks and it's just enough
painful where you're focused on
executing on it and so that's why we
charge for our products and I think if
you have a product you should always
charge for it because people will value
it more how does that Vibe with do
things for free
do things for free but if you want to do
things to accomplish them pay for them
it's it's the same thing as like
accountability buddy I mean if you
really wanted to accomplish something
you do two things you'd get an
accountability buddy to hold you uh to a
higher standard and you'd pay for help
to get it done I have a personal trainer
you know I have a nutritionist I work
with
um because I want to get there faster
and I will go to the gym if I'm going to
lose 100 bucks uh if I miss my training
session whereas often I will not go to
the gym if I don't pay for it because
it's easy to not um
yeah I think it's like in in fields like
you know if you want to learn if you
want to learn how to play tennis better
it's just kind of assumed that of course
you would hire a tennis coach but I
think one of the one of the good things
about information being free on the
internet is also one of the downsides of
information being free on the internet
that people think oh great the fact that
there is a
eight hour long YouTube video on how to
code in Python means that I should not
pay for this bootcamp but actually you
know paying for the thing gives you a
lot gives you accountability skin in the
game gives you a community gets you out
there and yes there are a lot of
self-starters who absolutely can learn
stuff for free on the internet but I
found this as well like with my with my
YouTuber Academy I'll have friends
messaging being like hey can I can I get
on this course yeah and I in the very
first cohort I would be like yeah of
course and not a single person even ever
logged in to make their account no but
now so now what I do is yeah I say pay
the five thousand dollars and if you
complete the homework I will refund you
the five thousand dollars and they all
do it and some of them just so some of
them have started YouTube channels at
the back of it and have now quit their
jobs because they had that skin in the
game others have done the six videos and
said you know what it's not for me can I
have my 5K back and I'm like yeah sure
here you go here you go but at least
they've done the work and it kind of
forces some level of accountability
right well it also shows that you value
yourself as the Creator because
oftentimes what I found is my friends my
friends friends family will want to have
a phone call right about buying a
business and the reason that I started
on the internet creating content uh was
basically I didn't want to answer the
same question a million times I'm not as
nice as you right so I was like no no
phone calls no coffees dear God help you
if you ask to pick my brain like also
gross visual like I don't want any part
of that and so
um so I started creating the content
because I was like I don't want to have
the same conversation 372 times and so
um I think it shows that you value
yourself when you start to charge for
the services that you render it's really
actually an important transfer of value
and it's and you know also I have a big
proponent that you shouldn't ask friends
for discounts you should pay premiums
and in fact if you want to support your
friend's business share it and pay for
it and most people forget those things I
would never ask a friend for a discount
and I never have even when I didn't have
a lot of money because I want the honor
of getting to pay for their hard work
what a beautiful thing you want to give
to charity you want to be known as a
charitable person but you don't want to
pay for the things that your friends
spent their precious hours creating it's
actually a little bit of an insult so
I'm very big on that and I think
our information is so good that what we
charge for it is so cheap that you are
crazy to not pay for it because if you
went to Harvard first of all you
couldn't get this information they don't
teach private equity in this way and I
had to spend you know seven months with
a vitamin D deficiency at Goldman so
that I could learn this stuff and work
70 hours a week and now you get it in a
compressed way I'm so thankful that
there are humans now on the internet
that create and share and I can pay for
it could you imagine if you could get a
supply chain class from Jeff Bezos I
would pay so much money for that but
most people do the selfish thing which
is they don't share the information now
we've kind of gotten it weird and
twisted because there's a bunch of
fraudsters on the internet who didn't do
anything who are creating things
sounding like they did they've tainted
the whole thing but in actuality most
humans in finance the same as we get
rich quietly we don't share our
practices it's a black box and now there
are humans that will actually tell me
how they did all of this and give me the
information I get to pay for that's a
incredible and and so I think
you have a moral prerogative to charge
for it because more people will actually
take action and if what we care about is
legacy and humans taking action and
that's what feeds our ego or our
Tombstone or whatever
um then I just follow the numbers and
that's what the numbers say nice Cody
this is an episode you want to follow
definitely do a part two table all of
the things content all of them more
about the business stuff uh maybe in
Austin want to come visit sounds like a
plan um any final piece of advice for
anyone who's Vibe with their maybe two
hours for this interview so far um who
who likes what you have to say and who
kind of Vibes with your way of thinking
any any pieces of advice maybe just that
a capable Optimist is worth
six times more than a brilliant
pessimist there's a whole world of
people who want to tell you why you
can't do things it's actually very cheap
and easy it's super easy to tell
somebody why something's not possible
it's actually quite hard to convince
somebody that they can and so I think
listening to things like this and
getting people to believe that they're
capable is hugely powerful so I think
it's really cool the platform that
you've built and I know you've
influenced lots of people including me
oh thanks very much appreciate it yeah
thank you so much for coming on my
pleasure all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye